[Music]
hello oh she thinks story fans I just
learned how to use green screens - Kip
pump for more [ __ ] like this okay enough
of that today we're covering Netflix's
lock and key taking a deep dive into its
ending finding out who exactly these
demons are and you'll want to stick
around for the end of the video as we'll
be going over what the ending could mean
for season 2
so smash that like button because here
we go what better way to start an ending
explained video then at the end with the
shocking revelation that Gabe is
actually the demon dodged in disguise
and that everyone's favorite condiment
Queen Eden has been taken over by a
demon as well but in order to really
understand how we got here we need to
travel back in time these are the
original keepers of the keys
Seventeen's who harness their powers but
ultimately bit off more than they could
chew
Elly tells us that their problems began
shortly after opening the black door a
portal to another world located in what
the graphic novels call the drowning
cave fun fact in the novel's there are
multiple doors in the cave with the
black door being the last one which
makes sense since the Omega symbol also
happens to be the last letter in the
Greek alphabet it's often used to denote
the end of things which is exactly what
happens when they open the door
unleashing an unknown demonic entity
from another realm who seeks to destroy
anything and everything in order to get
its hands on the keys unbeknownst to the
keepers Lukas was hit with one of these
demonic bullets its entity slowly taking
over his body leading to the tragic
deaths of Kim Jeff and Lucas himself and
they do what any teens would do in this
situation and dump them in the ocean
actually it's not that half bad of an
idea imagine going to the police and
telling them a demonic entity took
control of your best friend when you
used an ancient key on a portal to an
interdimensional realm not to mention
the riffle rules in effect now this
isn't really explained fully in the show
but the riffle rule is what disables an
adult's ability to directly see magic
the purpose of the rule was to
prevent adults from discovering using or
abusing the powers of the keys I'm
hoping we'll get a little more clarity
on this next season
now the keepers of the keys end up
giving them up vowing never to use them
except for Ellie whose life had taken a
downward toll with the death of her high
school sweetheart Lucas still weighing
heavily on her other people lives get
bigger for I felt like that was just a
Pyrrhic she hit her breaking point and
ventured to the well house using the
echo key to summon Lucas from the dead
but it's not really Lucas it's actually
the demon will come to know as dodge you
may have missed it but the show explains
the origins of the name dodge as a
nickname given to Lucas at school he was
a star fencer with a tremendous ability
to dodge and parry attacks so Ellie gave
him that nickname
Ellie could sense this wasn't the real
Lucas and was like hey great seeing you
and go some harder than the girls that
match me on tinder you see an echo can
only escape the well house by using the
anywhere key a key which allows its
wielder to travel through any door in
the world as long as they've seen it
before
when bodis mother gets stuck in the
mirror he comes running for dodges help
who subsequently tricks him and steals
the keys so she can chow down and steal
expensive jewelry by the way
edan eating a ton of food in the final
scene is a fun callback to episode 2
gaben Eden's demonic brunch wouldn't
have been possible without Dodge
completely foiling the locks family plan
to stop Dodge for good in fact at the
end of the season the lock family still
thinks everything is back to normal they
even decide to stay in Massachusetts
rather than pack up their things and
venture back to Seattle
by the way hate to break it to you guys
but this isn't actually Massachusetts
the show was shot in Nova Scotia and
Ontario fun things story fact I actually
went to school here not Matheson Academy
it's actually a college in Canada
in the novel's the story is set in
Lovecraft Massachusetts named after the
horror fiction writer HP Lovecraft but
it was author Joe Hill's idea to change
it to Matheson after Richard Matheson
the author of I am Legend some of you
may know author Joe Hill but may not
know he's the son of Stephen King and
even makes a guest appearance as a
paramedic in the final episode the show
is actually filled with cameos like
legendary prosthetic artist Tom Savini
who Scott Cavendish and his friends
named their friend group after but back
to the main dilemma that goes like dodge
cannot be killed I mean we literally
can't kill her ELISA decos can't be
killed by normal means so the gang
decides to trap it back where it came
from
the black door but dodge has her own
plans and she's armed with what's known
in the novels as the shadow crown when
it's combined with the shadow key
it essentially activates giving the
wielder the ability to control the
shadows we see this with dodges attack
on the lock house whose shadows are in
search of the Omega key the Omega key is
arguably one of the most important keys
and was the first to be made by Benjamin
Locke a great great ancestor of Tyler
Kinsey and bode way back in 1775 it's so
important in fact that Rendell Locke
buries it in his skull so no one can get
to it a fact that's only made known to
his family when Nina goes full crazy and
smashes the jar of ashes revealing these
still intact key
Benjamin Locke found the black door
while hiding during the American
Revolution accidentally letting the
children of laying escape the children
of laying are the demons whose world is
only accessible through that black door
in order to survive however they need a
human host demons who fail to find a
host turn into what's called whispering
iron although the show never mentions it
this is likely an example of it shown
here this iron is the same material that
the keys are made out of with bori
disintegrating dodges shadow with the
matchstick key the gang is led to
believe this body here is dodges but
this is all part of a greater master
plan we find out that dodge used the
identity key on Ellie turning her into
an identical copy of dodge so while the
gang thought they were throwing dodge
through the black door it was actually
Ellie who
the real world is simply considered a
missing person that really really sucks
but not as bad as Rufus who now has to
live with his uncle in Nebraska and hold
on a second can we just acknowledge how
much of a player dodges demon just
straight-up made up with Kinzie then two
seconds later uses the anywhere key and
makes out with her brother and don't
even get me started on this whole
polyamory storyline no thank you
so the family finally decides to let
Rendell's ashes go Nina had previously
kept the urn above the fireplace but
scattering the ashes over the cliffs is
symbolic of her in the family moving on
with their lives
Randall's death was the catalyst for
many of our characters weaknesses that
we had to see them overcome Kinzie for
example believes that she's a coward
when Sam lesser the team who killed her
father confronted her at gunpoint she
had the chance to try and attack him
with a fire poker but she was too afraid
to do it she's even afraid to go on a
date with Scott but by the end of the
season she's killed her own fear
literally and is open to dating multiple
people at the same time talk about a
change then there's Tyler who's haunted
by the death of his father he believes
that it's his fault Randall died in a
conversation with Sam he vents his
frustrations saying you ever do decide
to kill your dad and do me a favor
kill mine while you're at it it's four
episodes later that Tyler finds out his
words had nothing to do with Rendell's
death Sam killed Rendell because he was
being manipulated by dodge it had
nothing to do with what Tyler had said
this guilt weighs heavily on Tyler
throughout the season causing him to be
overprotective of those he loves to make
up for it when confronting an [ __ ]
hitting on his sister he wastes no time
beating the crap out of him this is
further personified when for a brief
moment the player turns into Sam with
their characters having changed and
everything hunky-dory all seems right in
the world until the revelation that
dodge had been secretly undercover as
Gabe via the identity key he also
happens to be the only one who witnessed
Eden get hit by one of those demonic
bullets this leads us with tons of
theories of where the show might be
headed with two demons on the loose and
both of them under cover a lot of damage
can be done now we know the Locke family
is in possession of several of the keys
as seen here and most importantly the
Omega key it's highly likely that Eden
and Gabe will use the element of
surprise to their advantage to gain
control of more of these keys and with
Scott essentially having cut ties with
Kinsley romantically that leaves our
undercover Gabe the perfect opportunity
to exploit his love with Kinsley in
order to access her box
I mean her musical box we also have the
relationship between Tyler and Jackie
now we know Jackie considers herself a
history buff and Anglophile heck Tyler
even throws a book about British history
in his head to learn more to impress her
and I think this could lead to Jackie
and Tyler looking more into the history
of the Locke family after all the event
which started the families entanglement
with the keys all centered around the
American Revolution against the British
we've only had a brief glimpse of the
ghost of Chamberlain Locke who roams the
graveyard on the lock estate but we
didn't get to learn at all about
Benjamin the original creator of the
keys I wouldn't be surprised if season
two delves more into the origins of the
keys not to mention a slew of keys that
are known in the books but haven't yet
been introduced in the show one such
important key is the Alpha key the only
object that can separate a demon from
the human soul that might sound like
good news for Eden but the process of
removing a demon from its human soul
results in the death of both now you
might think one I just used a head key
to travel into the brain and just remove
the demon that way
well since the demon latches onto your
soul and not your mind it simply doesn't
work that way
in the books the Alpha key is created by
Tyler so it's possible we could see him
creating new keys to combat Gabe and
Eden in season 2 now the show only
really covered about ten keys give or
take but throughout the graphic novels
there are roughly thirty four if you're
interested in learning more about these
keys I've left a link to the lock and
key wiki page in the description below
and we'll le come back well with Rufus
shipped off to Nebraska and the Locke
family really getting over quite quickly
I'd probably guess no le story and the
novel's is drastically different she
doesn't even get sucked into the black
door at all so unfortunately that
doesn't give us any clues it's still
uncertain whether lock and key will be
back for another season but with its big
cliffhanger and the growing popularity
of these haunted house type shows I'd be
surprised if it didn't come back
around 2:00 I hope you all enjoyed this
video please like and subscribe and tell
me in the comments below what you
thought of the show you can also reach
out and follow me on twitter @ think
story YT as the best way to stay in
touch until next time remember
[Music]